we're on problem 132 if the integer n is
greater than one is n equal to two so
they tell us that the integer n is
greater than one and they ask us is n
equal to 2 statement 1 n has exactly two
positive factors
exactly exactly
2 pause factors well that's certainly
true of the number 2 but it's also true
of any prime number I mean and could be
7 7 only has two positive factors 1 and
7 so it's true of any prime number so
this by itself isn't enough information
to say there's definitely two statement
2 tells us the difference of any two
distinct positive factors of n is odd
this is interesting the difference of
any two positive factors we're just
dealing in kind of the positive world
positive factors of n is odd so let's
think about it we were you know just
thinking about statement 1 we said okay
what numbers have only two factors
well prime numbers only have two factors
so this is only this only tells us that
n is prime right 2 is a prime number but
it's not the only prime number but for
most other prime numbers what do we know
about them well they're they're odd
right most prime numbers are odd let's
look at other than 2 or the other prime
numbers you go to 3 you go to 7 you go
to 11 and 5 and let me ask you why are
they odd because if they were even they
would be divisible by 2 and they
wouldn't be prime so by definition
really every prime number this not 2 is
not divisible by 2 because it's prime
and so they have to be odd numbers so
for any other prime number the number is
going to be 1 and itself so you know
let's call that P so the difference
between the two numbers and P is going
to be
odd number right every other prime
number other than two is odd so the
difference between the 2p minus one if I
take an odd number and I subtract one
from it I get an even number I get an
even number that's true for any odd
number so every other prime number is
odd and this this happens but they're
saying that when I subtract the
difference I get a odd I get an odd
number well the only number that that's
true for is two because the factors of
two or one and two and if I subtract one
from 2 to minus one is equal to one and
that's because 2 is the only even prime
number so you this the first statement
says we have to be dealing with a prime
number the second statement says well
the number really has to be an even
number if it is if it's going to be fine
let me think about the other two the
other if statement two alone is enough
difference of any two positive factors
of n is odd is odd any two positive
factors of n now this alone doesn't help
us because n could be I don't know it
could be one and six right the Dafina
one in six is five so it would satisfy
this so n could be six if we just took
statement two so we really need both
statement one tells us that n is prime
and statement two tells us that n has to
be even right there has to be an even an
even number so frankly there's there's
only one prime even number and that's
two so both statements together are
necessary to answer this question 133
133 every num every member of a certain
Club volunteers to contribute equally to
the purchase price of a 60 dollar gift
certificate how many members does a club
have so we want to know is called mm4
members how many members of the club
have question 1 each members
contribution is to be $4 so the members
so and let's see it says they contribute
equally to a purchase price okay so the
number of members times ever and they
say every member of a certain club so
now they don't say some members so m is
the number of members
and they contribute equally $4 and
that's going to be equal to $60 so then
you immediately know that you can solve
for the number of members there are 15
members of this club maybe I'm missing
something statement - if five club
members fail to contribute the share of
each contributing member will increase
by two dollars okay so that means that
if I were to take the amount that five
members were to contribute so let's say
that the contribution amount is C right
so if we take if we take the amount that
five members would contribute so five
times C and divide it by the remaining
members so divided by M minus five that
that would be that each contributing
member will increase by two right so
this is the amount that would have been
contributed by those five people let me
make sure that I'm not missing anything
and that is equal to $60 that is going
to be equal to two dollars right so this
is the amount that those five can
members would have contributed if they
don't contribute it it's going to have
to be divided by the other members so
however members there are minus five and
that is going to be when you divide the
amount divided by who has to pay for it
is $2.00 per leftover member and we also
know that the members times the
contribution for a member if everyone
pays is going to be equal to $60 that
they gave us in the problem statement
right that M members of a are going to
contribute equally and they're going to
end up with $60 so actually have two
linear equations in two unknowns so to a
statement two alone is actually
sufficient to solve this problem and if
this doesn't look like a linear equation
you can just multiply both sides by M
minus five and you get five C is equal
to 2m minus ten and now this looks a lot
more like a linear equation and actually
well actually this isn't a complete
linear equation but let me let me solve
it just to just a
make the point clear for you so if I
were to say that see this isn't a linear
equation so I shouldn't have said that C
is equal to 60 over m if C is equal to
60 over m so then this turns to 5 times
60 so 300 over M is equal to 2m minus 10
and then you are left with what multiply
both sides by M you get 300 is equal to
2m squared minus 10m divide both sides
by 2 you get 150 is equal to M squared
minus 10m and then subtract 150 from
both sides you get M squared minus 10m
minus 150 is equal to 0 and then let me
see if I can if I can just do this see
just by factoring it minus 150 C 30 30
times 30 times 5 no that's not good 15
times 10 so if I do M minus 15 times no
that doesn't work
15 25 and 6 I know one of the answers
already
I know it's 15 and minus 15 times M plus
10 oh actually I just realized what my
mistake was I went from this step to
this step so I divided both sides by 2
so 301 to 150 at 2m squared went to this
had to be 5m that's my mistake 5m m
squared minus 5n minus 150 so that's M
minus 15 times M plus 10 is equal to 0
so that tells us that M is equal to 15
or minus 10 so this was clearly not a
this is actually a quadratic equation
and we know that the members can't be
negative right there's positive number
of members so statement two alone is
enough information to know that there
are exactly fifteen members in this Club
next problem
that had me stumped there I could have
my careless mistake there for a second
next problem
and I am okay problem 134 34 so that
last one I don't know if I just said it
each statement alone is sufficient
so problem 134 if m and n are positive
integers positive integers is a square
root of n minus M an integer so m and n
are positive integers okay so they tell
us statement 1 they say n is greater
than M plus 15
well I'd you know this n is greater than
n plus 15 so if n is exactly 16 greater
than M this says this tells us that n
this is another way of saying that n
minus m is greater than 15 right that
tells us that what's under the
denominator is greater than 15 well if
what's under the Nama greater is 16 then
it is an integer but if it's 17 which
also meets this requirement it's not an
integer so this isn't enough information
by itself statement 2 says n n is equal
to M times M plus 1 which the same thing
is M squared plus M so if we substitute
that into this equation we get the
square root of M squared plus M plus M
minus M right M Squared that that's M
times M plus 1 it's N squared plus M and
this minus M is right there so that
cancels out we're just left with square
root of M Squared which is going to be
equal to M which is an integer so
statement two alone is sufficient to say
that this state this it would be an
integer as long as n is equal to M times
M plus 1 and I've run out of time see in
the next video